si vous êtes ici c'est peut-être que
vous faites partie des 50% des français
qui ont du mal à dormir il vous est
difficile de vous détendre avant de vous
coucher vous cogiter en pensant à votre
journée à votre emploi du temps du
lendemain il existe pourtant une
solution naturelle qui a fait ses
preuves depuis des générations
l'utilisation des plantes le fit aux
nuits en sachet à infuser un mélange
innovant de mélatonine l'hormone
naturelle du sommeil et de cinq plants
vous aide à vous endormir et bien dormir
alors ne pensez plus à rien et profiter
de cette séance de relaxation en
partenariat avec fit aux nuits le figaro
présente inspiration un podcast de
benjamin lubinski psy hypnothérapeute il
youtuber dites moi puis je vous offrir
une tasse de thé avec un nuage de
méditation et un soupçon d'hypnose ça me
ferait très plaisir parce que je
discutais récemment avec françois xavier
delmas
c'est un chercheur de thé et le
fondateur du palais d'été et on se
disait ceci le thé c'est toujours un
moment de partage
mais le t7 également toujours un moment
de méditation un moment pour soi ou un
moment qu'on partage mais toujours ce
recueillement que l'on retrouve ce
moment où on est bien calme posé et ceci
je crois presque à chaque fois un voyage
je dirais même un voyage en synesthésie
c'est à dire que rien que l'odeur du thé
son goût et vous voyagez dans vos
souvenirs comme la madeleine de proust
bien plus loin en asie en chine en corée
au japon est aujourd'hui moi je vais
vous faire voyager tout d'abord au
travers de la méditation
si vous avez déjà votre tasse de thé
c'est très bien sinon je vais vous en
offrir une
il suffira de fermer les yeux de le
départ pour faire ce voyage 1
et puis ensuite nous irons plus loin
vers le japon
et cette fois-ci porté par les ailes de
l'hypnose
alors si vous êtes prêts j'avais déjà
vous servir tout simplement une tasse de
thé voici également une tasse de thé
pour moi
c'est très bien
prenez le temps de bien vous installez
prononce au temps ensemble à échanger
vous savez simplement cette simple tasse
de thé observer ses couleurs observé la
lumière qui jouent en contraste à sa
surface
j'aime beaucoup cette expression il n'y
a pas deux brins d'herbe identique dans
un prêt et je crois que c'est très vrai
si on prend le temps simplement
d'observer cette tasse de thé votre
tasse de thé sa forme régulière
harmonieuse ses couleurs les reflets
et puis sinon porte plus loin
son observation si l'on se focalise sur
le thé en lui-même la manière qu'il a de
danser au fond de la tasse sa robe sa
couleur on peut même deviner sa texture
un peu et à la surface des reflets comme
un miroir un miroir aux pensées au
travers duquel notre regard pourrait se
brouiller nous pourrions dès maintenant
fermez les yeux et voyager voyager en
esprit ou bien encore rester quelques
instants sur l'observation sur la
méditation qui va avec le thé
elle peut l'apporter près de son nez
et en une inspiration très ample inspiré
tous ses arômes laisser ses sensations
se diffusait en nous et bien plus loin
que le nez dans les poumons presque dans
tout le corps vivre cette odeur vivre ce
bouquet y at il des odeurs de fruits des
odeurs de feuilles mortes
est-ce que vous commencez déjà peut-être
sous la forme de quelques images de
quelques sensations à voyager en vous
même
de toute façon nous avons tout le temps
c'est ça le sens du partage et aussi le
sens de la cérémonie du thé c'est de
prendre son temps
j'irai même plus loin et pour emprunter
leipold alexandre le bienheureux ce
magnifique film prendre le temps de
prendre son temps
alors
des yeux fermés en imagination
réellement face à cette tasse de thé eu
mes larmes que ses arômes vous
parviennent comme l'odeur délicieuse du
sacrifice aux narines des dieux et que
ses arômes remplissent votre corps et
votre esprit de détente de gamme et
simplement n'étant là en partageant se
tait on le ressent déjà le corps
commence à rentrer dans un état modifié
de conscience
ce sont des choses toutes simples
c'est la respiration qui est devenu plus
régulière au pas seulement pour bien
sentir le thé mais aussi pour pouvoir
lâcher prise se laisser porter par la
voix par le temps qui passe et à tant de
sensations dans un simple tu es comme si
le dépôt va être simple d'ailleurs il ya
le contact avec la tasse à chaque fois
différent
c'est l'un des plus beaux artisanat que
celui de la céramique ya la sensation de
la chaleur à chaleur au niveau de la
pulpe des doigts et qui semblent rentrer
un peu plus avant dans la chair
c'est un petit peu comme si le thé
s'emparer de nous quand on me poids mais
aussi quand on se sent quand on ressent
la chaleur on se laisse posséder par
cette sensation merveilleuse
alors il est aussi cette sensation
simplement porter une base l'impression
rassurante 7 à ce que l'on connaît déjà
cette à ce dont vous offre si c'est une
de vos tasses bien sûr c'est la
sensation d'avoir de quelque chose de
familier et si c'est un thé qu'on vous
offre la sensation du partage de
l'hospitalité et on va de la chaleur
humaine comme de la chaleur du thé elle
se partage
on peut la ressentir et ce sont deux
choses aussi matériel qu'immatériel et
peut-être peut-on aller encore plus loin
et prendre une gorgée de ce thé je vous
laisse la garder en bouche pour bien
ressentir les goûts sentez-vous son
amertume
son acidité son côté sucré à quel
endroit de la langue et peut-être du
palais ressentez vous tout cela c'est
agréable
c'est une sorte de complexité qui
forment une harmonie merveilleuse une
unicité harmonieuse
c'est ça un grand un botté
même si ce n'est pas un grand en beauté
c'est toujours un moment merveilleux un
moment pour soi alors reprenez une
gorgée ou laisser monter vous les arômes
encore une fois qui va-t-il en vous
d'autres arômes que vous connaissez bien
ou peut-être un souvenir si un souvenir
devait remonter à la surface lequel
serait-il lien ce que l'on appelle des
affects bridge le pont émotionnel peut
traverser sa pensée en passant par le
pont des émotions
c'est ça la madeleine de proust
ces saletés que nous partageons il ya
dans ce tte toutes les expériences que
vous avez vécu autour du thé bien sûr du
partage est peut-être ce premier
souvenir
ce premier souvenir d'importance bien
loin dans le temps c'est peut-être
quelqu'un que vous appréciez qui vous
servez une tasse de thé c'est peut-être
un endroit dans le monde
un voyage vous avez été couvert à
merveilleux des verres à thé jaune à aux
longues qui sait
quel est ce premier souvenir
d'importance celui vers lequel vous
allez voyager
porté par les ailes de la méditation
laisser les sons les sensations les
émotions aussi se préciser en vous des
images et laissez-vous la possibilité de
revivre ce moment merveilleux et pendant
ce temps là votre respiration va encore
s'approfondir et plus vous allez rentrer
vivre cette première expérience et plus
vous allez entrer profondément danse
aussi simplement que cela la respiration
qui devient plus lourde plus régulière
le corps qui se détend tout le corps
sauf le bras ou la main
qui porte la tasse en vrai mon
imagination
celle là pfff simplement rester comme ça
comme suspendu dans le vide comme tenu
par un fil
et servir de présentoirs à ce tte
merveilleux tandis que de l'autre côté
de votre imagination
du côté de l'inconscient ce rêve se
souvenir se précise
et tandis que de l'autre côté de votre
esprit se souvenir prend forme réalité
et vie en vous alors le bras votre bras
celui qui ne tient pas le thé celui ci
peut devenir lourd les jambes ceux ci
peuvent devenir lourd et la respiration
continue à s'alourdir profondément et
vous rentrez toujours plus avant dans ce
souvenir et il n'est plus importante ne
plus avoir de ne plus dit de ne plus
penser même la présence des vocations de
voyage la sensation le souvenir ce que
en soi pour soi
cela représente comme si dans cet
échange entre les sens
la mémoire l'hypnose la méditation
tout cela mélangé porté par les vapeurs
du thé et par ce secret mystère je le
dire cette alchimie vous entrez encore
plus entre
vous continuez à vivre ce souvenir
je vous parlait d'elle chimie c'est vrai
qu'il ya quelque chose de mystérieux
comment se fait-il que quelques feuilles
séchées jeté à la pâte dans de l'eau
chaude puisse donner ce fut merveilleux
cette subtilité cette complexité
complexité tout aussi grande que celle
du vin et contrairement au vin le thé
est universel partout on boit le thé est
partout on peut retrouver cette
merveilleuse plantes qu'elle camellia
sinensis l'arbre à thé de teillé mais ce
n'est pas partout que le thé peut
développer ses arômes il faut un terroir
il faut que l'eau le soleil l'altitude
le climat les sels minéraux de la terre
s'unissent pour créer des feuilles
chargé et en saveurs et ses feuilles ses
feuilles tout jeune que l'on récolte
chaque année eh bien ce sont elles qui
sait chez oak site est travaillée par la
main de l'homme vont se transformer en
quelque chose de merveilleux
et comme un alchimiste
il suffira de mélanger la pierre
philosophale
du coup le thé encore sec et de le
mélanger c'est tout rémy sentent pour
laisser l'esprit du thé gagner l'eau se
répandre ils ne formaient plus qu'un ont
été merveilleux qui porte en lui toute
la marque tout le souvenir de l'endroit
où la poussée des mains qu'ils ont
récolté des mains qu'ils ont travaillé
des mains qui ont façonné alors peu
importe si c'est un thé jaune un thé
blanc des verts a pou r encore à des
dons pointe et de lumière peu importe
qu'ils viennent du japon de corée de
chine du vietnam ou d'autres pays même
le kenya la tanzanie même l'australie il
véhicule avec lui tant de choses
le thé est un extrait de nature de vie
de travail
de savoir faire
alors si vous le souhaitez poser cette
tasse de thé
continuez à siroter encore quelques
instants et je pense qu'il est
maintenant temps de laisser ses
paupières se clore
si ce n'était pas déjà le cas pour
passer de la méditation à l'hypnose ce
mot un peu vieilli la transe et il n'y a
pas d'efforts à faire il suffit de
laisser la voix stahl est en vous
les conditions de l'hypnose avec autant
de facilité qu'il y a à boire une tasse
de thé
les pensées s'accroche se décroche et
peu importe le moment l'instant nature
et où même la perception du temps
parfois ainsi rapides et d'autres fois
si lente
tu me manques que c'est l'instant
lui-même en ce qu'il recouvre défini
façonne et recréer cet instant lui même
donc pour lui m ou plus précisément au
travers de lui-même qui nous pousse à
entrer en transe et dans le souvenir des
pensées dans celle qui se construisent
celle qui se rejoignent dans la
construction même de nos expériences des
apprentissages qu'ils créent de la vie
qui s'offre à nous de notre vie qui se
précise au travers d'elle dans cette
rencontre merveilleuse entre votre
subjectivité et nature même du monde
cette rencontre si entre votre goût et
le goût du thé il y a cette entrée en
transe toute douce calme tranquille
ici tout n'est que luxe calme et volupté
et j'ai envie de dire
pour plagier baudelaire car le thé
suttil jeter c'est le plus grand des
petits plaisirs que l'on peut s'offrir
t
c'est un temps pour soi autant rien qu'à
soi
et alors
laissez votre corps retrouvés maintenant
sa position la plus confortable et
laissez-vous simplement porté par ma
voix
j'aimerais que la distance s'efface que
vous fassiez presque le tour de la terre
et que votre esprit inconscient
maintenant vous fasse vivre vous fasse
ressentir vous fasse expérimenté ce que
c'est que d'être dans une belle maison
japonaise et à ces paravents
il y a
peut-être ce fut ton sur le sol une
chambre presque dépouillé mais
harmonieuse
car si le zen apprend quelque chose c
est laisser partir
tout ce qui n'est pas essentiel ce matin
votre hôte à vous faire faire le plus
merveilleux des voyages car il va vous
convier à la cérémonie du thé observer
les cloisons en papier qui vous sépare
du jardin sec
ce jardin fait de petits cailloux de
grandes pierres ce sable ces cailloux
fin ratissé tous les jours pour former
comme des sortes de vagues car ce jardin
sec qui va s'offrir à vos yeux
maintenant que votre hôte ouvre les
cloisons qui vous sépare de ce dernier
ce jardin sec donc ce jardin zen va
commencer à vous faire voyager percevoir
ce quelle harmonie
percevoir ce que c'est que d'être centré
sur l'instant présent et même si vous
n'avez pas toutes les connaissances de
votre hôte bien sûr vous savez que les
pierres ces grandes pierres représente
des zigs des îles mystique au delà du
royaume des hommes et le sable
ces petits cailloux blancs ces
ondulations ce sont les vagues les
vagues des mers et des océans un autre
monde
alors si tout à fait normal si l'esprit
rentrer davantage en transe car plus on
s'absorbe dans l'expérience et dans
l'instant plus on rentre en soi même
c'est comme si la perception du monde
extérieur
besset pour laisser place à un monde
intérieur plus riches et vous allez
progresser ainsi que dans un rêve sans
effort
votre hôte maintenant avec délicatesse
avec cette politesse exquise qu'ont les
japonais
ce souci de l'autre cette manière de
dire toujours les bons mots ce qui
permet de se sentir respecté avec un
rien de discrétion et sans insistance et
vous invitent ainsi l'accompagner pour
une promenade dans son beau jardin
japonais et chaque fois que vous referai
7 hypnose
il sera peut-être un peu différent c'est
très bien comme ça car c'est le
territoire de votre inconscient que nous
traversons ensemble alors peut-être
pourrez-vous voire de merveilleuses
arbres taillés en nuage peut-être
pourrez-vous voir la floraison
merveilleuse des azalées peut-être vous
laisserez-vous bercé par le bruit de
l'eau l'ont peut-être pourrez-vous
observé un jardin de mousse car au japon
c'est aussi utiliser la mousse des bois
pour recouvrir le sol et recrée avec
ordre et harmonie ce qu'il ya de plus
beau dans la nature
peut-être un moment avez vous envie de
vous asseoir et de laisser votre regard
se perdre dans la contemplation de
carpes koï qui danse bien vrai vous
envie de simplement regarder les nuages
dans le ciel est de vous laisser bordés
porter loin loin dans votre imagination
il est agréable d'être protégé par ce
jardin et de l'arpenter ainsi qu'à le
nombre en parlant tout bas blancs tout
pas parce qu'il pense qu'il ya quelque
chose de sacré parce que finalement
quand on prend le temps lorsque l'on à
cet art de vivre toutes choses se
transformer un spiritualité
le japonais faire un bouquet quelque
chose de spirituel travailler son jardin
se promener dans celui ci est ce si la
cérémonie du thé nous savons tous le
temps pour nous diriger vers cette
petite cabane qui est la maison de thé
endroit spécifique celui qui offre la
perspective la plus merveilleuse sur ce
jardin la plus apaisante et
promenez-vous encore quelques instants
rien ne presse c'est très bien
votre hôte s'accompagne cette maison de
thé les cloisons sont déjà ouvertes et
vous pouvez observer c'est une femme
habillée avec un kimono d'une manière
traditionnelle
elle est agenouillé elle vous attend
votre hôte s'agenouillait aussi et bien
sûr vous le suivez dans ce geste est
désormais tout invite au silence pour
observer les gestes précis les gestes
charge et la sagesse d'une civilisation
ancienne d'une civilisation unique
ces gestes chargé de spiritualité ces
gestes où se mêlent tous les apports du
bouddhisme peut-être du shintô x ou
peut-être simplement du savoir-vivre
japonais
il ya cette fine poudre de thé le match
à cette manière qu'elle a deux tournées
sorte de fouet en bambou pour que l'eau
se mélange au matcha se tait merveilleux
ce thé qui porte en lui toute la nature
car lorsque vous buvez une tasse de
match à vous sentez la nature entière
chaque gorgée à chaque inspiration
lorsque vous aimez le thé
n'ai pas besoin de comprendre ce qui se
passe cette manière si précises de
saisir les instruments de verser l'eau
de tourner les bols de vous serviez dans
ces grands bas n'est pas là matcha
il n'y a pas besoin de comprendre pour
ressentir et qu'il est beau qu'il est
doux qu'il est bon
de boire se tait en observant les grands
champs de teillé au loin qui épouse la
forme des montagnes et transmute ses
flancs des vagues dans des océans
vous êtes bien là maintenant le temps ne
compte plus
et chaque gorgée chaque instant dur
l'éternité un jour la respiration de
plus en plus profondes
le corps maintenant parfaitement
immobile calme serein l'esprit se vide
pour se remplir de cet instant de la
magie de cette cérémonie du thé de la
beauté harmonieuse de ce jardin et
l'immensité élégante c'est chante t
alors que certains endroits le ciel
la nature se reflète la surface d'une
petite mare ou à la surface d'un petit
ruisseau
tout devient calme et le monde
et vous même vous sentez à quel point
l'esprit en communion avec ce qu'il vit
et ressent à la fois une émotion
éternelle qui dépasse la permanence des
shows cette impermanence est aussi là
pour vous rappeler de cueillir le jour
carpediem dirait ton l'autre côté de la
terre cueille le jour saisit l'instant
est à toi lentement d'aller vers une
plus grande sérénité
vous allez pouvoir rester aussi
longtemps que vous le souhaitez dans
cette maison de thé au milieu de ce
jardin de ses champs de thé au milieu
des montagnes au milieu du japon milieu
des mères
au milieu du royaume des hommes alors ma
voix va se transformer en une douce
brise et donner encore plus de sérénité
et de vie à cet endroit merveilleux
rester aussi longtemps que vous le
souhaitez ici on vous le voudrez vous
pourrez fermer les yeux et cette fois-ci
aller dans un autre au royaume à celui
des esprits mais celui du monde des
rêves ma voix ne sera comme une sorte
d'arrière fond à votre inconscient au
territoire de vous pensez et celle ci à
voix mais aussi donc vos songes les
rênes
la continuité de la tension la manière
qu'ont les choses
se dit de se voir de s'entendre parfois
même de se révéler comme tant de trésors
autant de découvertes au temps du temps
le sien et celui du monde à l'instant
arrêtée au temps suspends ton vol
mais si ce n'est pas possible alors des
sons l'esprit captée dans l'instant le
secret de l'éternité
laissons les yeux
observez les ombres et les lumières
canton ce merveilleux traité de casanova
qui
laissons l'imagination rêver de temples
mystérieux perdu là haut dans les
montagnes les sons l'esprit rêver ces
renards magique du folklore japonais aux
esprits qui peuplent la terre les lieux
et les choses bien restons dans ce
jardin
la décision vous appartient
car l'esprit inconscient libres et
créant vous ce rêve ce rêve d'expérience
cette expérience du rêve les mots plus
une musique qu'autre chose
mon rythme lent une mélodie douce
comme mouvement des failles dans le vent
enfin la twa sauvage la surface talent
course des nuages à tence d'un pinceau à
calligraphie dessine en donnant vie à
des lettres donne envie à des
idéogrammes peut-être c est ce temps
merveilleuse ses peintures de la berd i
do ou d'avant peut-être le souvenir dont
des temps plus anciens de temps et sa
mort à des seigneurs peut-être aussi
d'autres influences chaque soir chaque
nuit un rêve différents un rêve de japon
pendant que les pensées s'accroche se
décroche quand vous le sommeil se
développe pour réveiller les rêves pour
laisser inconscient
prendre toute sa place jusqu'au sommet
car la respiration devient on se met y
est le corps lourd est calme maintenant
un peu engourdie
car l'esprit qui voyagent porté par le
vent laisser se reposer
de son côté la respiration régulière
bien sûr et la sensation du temps doux
qui nous traversent nous fait grandir ne
dirige plus en plus vers ce que nous ça
quelque chose d'essentiel
et vous savez bien que lorsque vous
reprendrez un thé c'est merveilleuse
sensation réapparaîtront il suffira de
fermer les yeux on le déguste en
maintenant juste se laisser porter pour
dormir bien pour certains ouvert les
yeux complètement relaxer et call pour
les sourds où dormait
porté par la respiration qui vous berce
régulière dans la voix plus lente
maintenant +12 7 voient rien que pour
vous dans la nuit du temps qui passe ton
inconsciente l'esprit au rythme des mots
sur la longueur des phrases emporter ou
plutôt regret par l'inconscient votre
imagination qui donne au mot sens et
forme votre imagination votre
inconscient c'est l'eau qui révèle
l'esprit des feuilles du thé alors on se
laisse porter
à l'instant se laisse dériver vers le
cas relaxé bien sera on peut
tu as remis
tamir doucement dormir sereinement
et comme si l'on pouvait fermer les yeux
à nouveau dans le monde des rêves sans
dormir encore plus profondément et
dérivés avec douceur au redépart les
ruisseaux de l'âme jusqu'au lendemain
vous dormez vous dormez vous dormez
sept séances de bien-être vous a été
proposé en partenariat avec le fit aux
nuits le fit aux nuits en sachet à
infuser un mélange innovant de
mélatonine l'hormone naturelle du
sommeil et de cinq plants pour
s'endormir et bien dormir
bonne nuit avec le complément
alimentaire fit aux nuits